good morning friends this is the second
day in the life video that I've made and
the last one was literally years ago
look I'm gonna be honest today is not a
regular day I may have chosen a
particularly cool day it's kind of
cheating I know so today is Tuesday
December 12th and I gotta get up and go
to work but then I'm leaving walk at 2
p.m. because I got invited to Lucasfilm
headquarters in San Francisco to see the
lost Jedi early I'm very excited there
won't be any spoilers in this video
don't worry about that yeah first is we
actually gotta get changed so this has
situation I don't and go to IGN
alright it is time to go got my protein
shake that I drink on my walk and I
think I realized it's probably a little
bit weird is that I always leave my
makeup at work and I put it on when I
get to work rather than ever putting it
on in HoN but yeah let's go to work
[Music]
all righty made it to work I actually
stopped working on daily fix scripts
while I'm walking to work but now it's
the part where go write it and take 20
minutes and then put makeup on alrighty
it is time to put makeup on so this is
the back end of our studio this is Dan
hi he is loading scripts into the
teleprompter right now for me to go in
there and read this is not Dan's actual
face no it's a fake face I'm working and
they're just love someone who doesn't
hear and then again all right and then
through this way is where we actually
shoot things I'm trying to like record
myself doing the fix but because it's so
white I just come up is this like crazy
white silhouette on my phone I actually
kind of look like an angel
so that's pretty cool Roland's 2017 has
been the butt of a lot of jokes but man
it's been a good year for Nintendo much
better than the year of Luigi
[Music]
so in preparation for me going to
Australia in two weeks time we're also
pre recording some stuff for the break
today is oh that's the wrong side
today is a top 5 WTF moments some of the
weirdest stuff that has happened in 2017
I wrote this yesterday so according it
now and it'll be up in like the 28th of
December or something alright we
finished recording the two fixes I'm now
making myself some breakfast then I
gotta rewrite some lines and record some
vo for a cosplay thing and then I'm
gonna try and fit in somewhere today to
record one of my op-ed videos but I
don't know if that's going to work we'll
see how that goes
wish me luck okay finished breakfast it
looks like I'm actually gonna be able to
fit in all of the things I need to do
today I'm going to the video booth to
record a video for the cosplay piece
right can we get some sounds hey friends
I'm Alana and today we're talking about
the price of doing hey
I'm Alana and today we're talking about
the price of video games
I've spoken pretty harshly about
microtransactions in videos here this
year and every time people respond and
that's it the video is done and we're
good
hey respond anyway catch us next time
hey this is what I'm gonna use out it's
just 30-second video alright see you
guys next time bye
[Music]
all right I actually got most of my walk
done and ended up writing a little bit
about a feature as well that I've been
working on for a few months so it is
officially time to go to Lucasfilm we're
heading an hour and a half early which
seems crazy to me but apparently it'll
take us a while to get there and we want
to make sure we get good seats in the
theater because it's not allocated
seating I don't want to like see this
movie for the first time sitting in the
crappy front row so let's go
[Music]
trying not to squint but it's not
walking so I made it to the Presidio
which is I guess well Lucasfilm is we're
not allowed to check-in to Lucas for
another ten minutes so I just took a
walk around to this this crazy beautiful
part of San Francisco that I've never
been to it's about 25 minute drive from
our office and it's just so green and
this trees everywhere and it's just like
spacious it feels like I'm on a
different city honestly
[Music]
all right so we were being asked to
check our phones and now we're not
allowed to take them into the theater
which I totally understand wasn't
planning on filming anything anyway but
I will see you guys often I've seen so
we just got out of the movie I'm not
gonna say anything except holy crap so
I've got a free pool
it's so freakin cute everyone who went
got one so that's rad so I'm starving
right now
we're going to go get food and talk
about it and I discuss theories and
stuff already left and then I just went
straight to the gym I am now officially
exhausted it's pretty late but yeah we
spoke to like I don't know an hour about
theories and stuff that these portal is
I'm very excited to see what everyone
else thinks of it and like see the
theories coming out because it's one big
question that I have that I'm very
curious about so yeah I wish I could
show more enthusiasm but yeah I don't
want to ruin anything it was just it was
super fun I really enjoyed it and I
can't wait to see it again at the end of
this week but yeah I'm gonna go home now
I'm gonna edit this very video and then
upload it and then gonna make my lunch
for tomorrow and have a shower and all
that good stuff so I'll see you guys
next time